yeah your fights oh boy you know people
some people wonder if the show's
scripted or not but in those moments I
have two sisters and I'm like
the way you go at it yeah but then you
know you gotta make up right right yeah
we always make up at the end of the day
what is your problem what is your
problem you've been nitpicking at me all
freaking day
totally butt heads on and off camera
everybody knows but you know what we
love each other we want to we get you
know we want the last word you know we
want to have each other's back but we
want to be heard
for each other and um for ourselves as
well so I think it's just having that
last word and it triggers us so that day
that we had that blowout for tap blow
out yeah you know it was real there's no
faking that there's no we are you can't
script that authentic we're real we are
100 we
we don't fake anything we are who we are
either you love us or you hate us we
just
we live life tell it like it is well I
don't want to rip the Band-Aid off but
we have to talk about it Stacy you
mentioned that Darcy picks toxic men I
feel like she has a tendency to pick men
that are toxic for her why do you think
that is what do you think that's been
the case
still trying to figure that out because
I mean I know she deserves so much more
and
she's you know just
she radiates like love and positivity I
just feel like
you know these these guys that she she
attracts they just suck her energy and
things like suck your energy dry and I
don't know I just feel like
people leech on to that that kind of
positive energy
they want it they want to give it yeah
and then I feel like they get
intimidated by it yeah and then they you
know it's like there's things that can
trigger me and it's just it's not fair
it's not right like um
yeah so I've got to put up strict
boundaries now in my life and just
really take my time finding the right
one well another thing Darcy Stacy
mentioned before that she hoped that you
find your one like she's found Florian I
just want her to find
for true love like Halloween have do you
ever these two ever feel like there is
some sort of like competition sisterly
competition I wouldn't say a competition
um we want the best for each other yeah
you know or maybe like you know
I think it's only natural for some when
we want something and someone close us
has it to be happy for them of course
but you still have that feeling of like
I want it right you know I think you
want the same thing I want the same
thing it doesn't have to be exactly the
same but similar I feel like we tend to
one-up each other a lot of the times
yeah yeah I see it though
it has its cute moments within their the
real moments there too you know I think
that sometimes we put such a Negative
like
thing around jealousy when it is a
natural human emotion you know so it's
like just naturally Darcy do you have
moments where it's like you see your
sister in love and you know yeah at
times I feel you know she's happy I want
to be happy too do I prepare myself
wanting to have a relationship like her
foreign
so tell us about this cosmetic procedure
that you all are having this season It
looks interesting it's happening down
there it happens down there it's called
the oh shots and what they do is they
take PRP which is they take your own
blood they put it through a machine and
then they shake it to
um take the red part away of the blood
and if you're left with liquid gold
Liquid Gold The PRP PRP and then they
inject it inside the um the vaginal area
of the walls yeah tighten it to make you
like you know more young and Youthful
American yeah and they're amazing oh
yeah yeah that's why they called the
OSHA yeah if Aspen or Annika wanted to
do some sort of cosmetic procedure are
you like fully on board with that
when they get older and they you know I
think if they want to do facials I
wouldn't say like botox they're perfect
too they want to go for a fun facial or
something like that yeah you know that's
okay but I don't think they need any
sort of cosmetic procedures to enhance
what they already have because they're
natural beauty yeah yeah too and you
know what I feel like we started later
in life we didn't try Botox until we
were 35. yeah you know we both had our
kids you know things were kind of taking
you know going down we just wanted to
lift everything up thank God my best
friend's coming
there's the ax Georgia
it's good to have him big mother problem
Georgie makes a return this season
Darcy first of all did you know him and
Florian were keeping up
I don't really know I knew a little bit
but I didn't really know that there were
new BFFs yeah you got him his best
friend I know so I was a little shocked
by that
um but when we were all together it was
always the four of us so he probably was
missing that Dynamic and maybe an Orient
shoe because we were new to Miami and we
didn't have a lot of friends at that
time so I think he likes to keep in
touch with people yeah and Georgie
obviously was the closest person to him
since we moved from Connecticut and I
think that he needed someone and they
just created a bond you know I don't I
don't sit and listen to his
conversations and stop like he's allowed
to be friends with whoever he wants and
yeah I'm not going to take that away
from him but it is it it definitely was
kind of a slap in the face
yeah it was so tough it was tough for
you yeah because I feel like I fully had
moved on it's been months see him again
he has his own haircut yeah he looks
good he does look good yeah
yeah
I don't know they like the copycat he's
blonde and now he has veneers they get
mad that we did all these surgeries and
then they get in teeth and hair it's
like I'm like there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with the blow up yeah like
geez but she said good you you kept
moving on huh yeah and if you could
describe the rest of the season in one
word what would it be
oh yeah and the song
yeah yeah we have a new song
because it's the theme song now yeah the
theme song is good yeah so wait that was
your song yeah
[Music]
congratulations we did that years ago
waiting for any TV show and I just feel
like everything comes full circle wow
just things man I've got this like wow
that actually happened it's kind of like
everything like just becomes full circle
so well thank you back to that time when
you were making songs and just you know
and seeing yourself now how does that
feel you come along
we manifested yeah we've always
visualized ourselves doing big things
you know growing our company with House
of 11 Going Global you know even
and you know what yes we've had a lot of
you know ups and downs and times when
we've you know failed or fell down but
we got right back up together you know
hand in hand like we always do like this
yeah yeah I feel like have our you know
our dads that they in that that
mentality that we uh grew up called
Silver strong we want to make our family
proud yeah be your brother supporting
from from above that's right I love how
much y'all like you know still
acknowledge his spirit and it's
beautiful yeah it's definitely guiding
us yeah yeah like we were the Eagles in
the sky doing the parents that's so
crazy I had a dream about him last night
wow yeah my chili bottle last night it
comes to us all the time that's
beautiful definitely guiding us yeah
foreign